MATT GAUNT: Hi.
I'm Matt Gaunt, a developer
advocate here at Google.
And in this video, we'll catch
a glimpse of an undulating
monkey, have some
crazy robot talk,
and I even get to take a
trip to Hawaii, all thanks
to the latest web
view in Android.
When we released
KitKat, the WebView
changed from being based on
WebKit to being Chromium based.
Initially, this was
version M30 of Chrome.
And the big win
with this release
was support for DevTools.
In KitKat MR2, we updated
the WebView from M30 to M33,
meaning it came with all the
usual security and bug fixes
that you'd get in a
new version of Chrome.
The WebView team also worked
on improving the canvas
performance and added support
for screencasting and DevTools.
Now with the developer
preview of L,
we're updating
the WebView to M36
and enabling some additional
web platform features.
If you haven't already
tried using DevTools
to debug you WebViews, you need
to go and add this line of code
into your app right now, calling
setWebContentsDebuggingEnabled
to true, you'll actually
enable DevTools debugging,
and I admit that is
quite a mouthful.
You can enable this
just for debug builds
or for release builds.
It's entirely up to you.
But once you've enabled
it, plug your phone
into your computer
with a USB cable,
open up Chrome on your computer,
and go to Chrome inspect.
Here, you'll see entries
for every single web view
inside of your app,
and clicking on inspect
will open up DevTools.
Now, it's worth
mentioning that you
should have a desktop version
of Chrome equal to or newer
than the WebView version.
So for the developer
preview of L,
you're going to need to use
Chrome Beta or Chrome Canary.
With DevTools open,
you'll have access to DOM
and the CSS inside
of your WebViews.
Here, you can make
changes and you'll
see them immediately take
effect inside of your app.
The JavaScript console is
useful for viewing console.log
messages, as well as
manually executing
JavaScript inside your WebViews.
Now, one crazy useful
trick I realized
is if you've got a JavaScript
interface that you're
adding into the WebView just
so that you can communicate
from JavaScript to
native, you can actually
call those native
methods directly
from the DevTools console, which
makes debugging this bridge
logic just a tiny bit easier.
The Network tab enables you to
view whatever network requests
are happening
inside of your page.
Now, this is useful
for anyone who's
loading a page on a remote
server, so a normal URL.
But it's also useful for
anyone loading a static web app
from the APK, because if
they're making XHR calls,
you can actually view the
requests and the responses,
as they'll all show
up in the Network tab.
And it's just a little bit
easier than logging everything.
Then there's a timeline.
If you ever notice any jank
inside of your web app,
this is the place you should
go to get an insight into what
Chrome is spending its
time doing for each frame.
Generally, you want to
look out for long running
tasks or tasks that are
happening repeatedly
and see if there's anything you
can do to alleviate the issue.
The last thing I wanted
to mention on DevTools
is screencasting.
Screencasting was enabled
in KitKat MR2 and above,
and it allows you to
interact with your web app
directly from DevTools.
It means you don't need to
switch from your computer
to your device.
You can just do everything
from your computer.
Now, a nice side
effect of this is
let's say you have a WebView
that's currently off screen.
And we can animate
it in later on.
You can actually use the
screencasting feature
to see what the WebView is
rendering, even though it's not
visible screen.
I mentioned that
the WebView team
have been working to
improve canvas performance.
Here, we have some stats from
the Vellamo Benchmark Suite.
And you can see improvements
of around 200 to 350%
for these tasks.
Now let's take a look
at some of the new web
features we've been able
to [INAUDIBLE], starting
with the undulating monkey
I promised you at the start.
In the developer preview of L,
we've added support for WebGL.
Here, you can see a
demo from Paul Lewis
and quite frankly,
I love this monkey.
Next up is the web audio.
Web audio API is an important
part for any web based game.
But it also enables you to
manipulate sounds, create
synths, or play with the
microphone input, which
is why I have a
crazy robot voice.
The final new web feature
enabled is WebRTC.
You can now use data
channels for sharing data
or get user media to
access the camera.
All of this means I can
now do things like this.
Hey Sam.
SAM: Hey Matt.
How's it going?
You're in Hawaii?
MATT GAUNT: There we go.
We've looked at DevTools, seen
a WebGL undulating monkey.
I've got to talk like a
robot and take a green screen
trip to Hawaii.
For guides and additional info
on the Chrome based WebView,
check out this link.
Cheers.